(rap music)
- Oh my God, oh my God! Hold on.
My costar,
Gwyneth, is in the chat.
Hi Gwyneth.
Gwyneth, oh she knows Tyler.
- It's Ty's birthday too.
- [Gary] And it's
Ty's birthday guys.
34 years old, looking good.
(rap music)
("Summertime Soul" by Kyle)
Go speak to the ones
that have won the game,
who have been able
to play the patience
game and let it come to them and
go speak to the ones that are no
longer here, whether by
their choice for our choice,
and all I just know 80% of them
regret not holding their breath,
you know, another six months.
This arbitrary like self-esteem
wrapped up in title play,
it just makes no sense when
you've got everything going for
you and you're literally willing
to change the course of your
life and career
because of impatience on
a six or 12 month trajectory.
This is good, thank you.
("Summertime Soul" by Kyle)
What's up Instagram?
Vayner Nation if you are
available on June 28th and you
want to take your business or
personal brand or organization
to the next level, we've
started this 4Ds program,
email me at
gary@vaynermedia.com,
gary@vaynermedia.com
and I will have Tyler
forward the emails to
the group here and
we'll get on the call.
We'll get on the phone today
and give you the
answers to the details.
We've also got a video that has
and I saw the
highlight reel to the 4Ds.
(light music)
- [Steve] The Daily Digital Deep
Dive is a one day immersion into
digital marketing the way that
we do it here at VaynerMedia.
It's the behind-the-scenes
look at the way we operate,
we're going to introduce
everyone to the different
department heads.
These folks come together to
share both the tools and tips
that sets them apart
in the marketing space.
- [Man] The best content will
always provide a personal value.
- [Woman] As adaptive animals,
people have sort of changed
their habits and behaviors.
- As well as what
they've learned from Gary.
- [Claude] I knew what he was
really saying to me is culture
is always created
from the top down.
- [Steve] Or other things that
are kind of the intangibles of
what's made us Vayner.
- So what you just watched
is our sizzle reel for 4Ds.
My email is
right here, right now,
gary@vaynermedia.
Just the Claude part is
worth $10,000 for your business.
I just genuinely believe that.
- [Tyler] We got to go.
- [Gary] We gotta go.
- [Tyler] Yep.
- [Gary] Why are
you such a dick, Ty?
Hold on, let's ask
Tyler, let's ask Tyler.
- That's his job
to be a dick kinda.
- [Gary] Well you used
to have Ty's job, Nate.
(group laughter)
Now, from your perspective,
Nate, who's better
at this job: you or Ty?
- It's a little
different world.
- [Gary] I know
but what do you think?
Deep down, you, right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
And Ty, you?
- [Tyler] Yeah,
there's no doubt.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And Scott, do you
ever want to have that job?
- I think I can go for that.
- [Gary] Well not based
on that whole August,
July thing.
(group chatter)
Oh my God, oh my God! Hold on.
My costar,
Gwyneth, is in the chat.
Hi Gwyneth.
Gwyneth, oh she knows Tyler.
- It's Ty's birthday too.
- [Gary] And it's
Ty's birthday guys.
34 years old, looking good.
Gwyneth, I love you.
(blows kisses) The world
gets to see our stuff soon.
Love you so much. Miss you.
See you soon, I hope.
Okay, got to go
'cause Tyler's being mean.
Love you, email me if
you're interested in the 4D.
I'll get these
two handsome men
on the phone
with you right away.
Gwyneth, I love
you, talk to you later.
("Music" by K.A.A.N.)
- [Carmine] 'Sup Gary?
- [Gary] Sup, man?
- My God, it's Carmine.
Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Carmine.
- [Andrew] 'Sup? Andrew.
- [Gary] Andrew,
such a pleasure.
How are things?
- [Carmine] Fantastic.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Andrew] Going super well.
- [Gary] Great.
Any value I can
bring you guys in this
quick five minute
meet and greet?
- Honestly, this is one
thing I've was telling Tyler,
is I don't really have
an agenda in meeting Gary.
- [Gary] Other than
creating context, right?
- Yeah, I just think you bring a
message to a lot of people that
is massively valuable.
And you've been obviously giving
a lot of direction to myself and
other people.
So my mom says you are
so it's just one of those things
I'm in the city and
I just wanted to
make the connection.
- [Gary] I'm glad. I get it.
That would be my move, right?
Build on context.
Especially when you have
nothing that you really need,
the best thing to do is
just face to name, handshake.
You build.
You never know, we may
talk in 27 years from today.
Like I plan on being
around and doing shit.
You know?
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- So I get it.
I appreciate it.
I'm glad you're here.
- [Carmine] I have
all this energy.
I'm working like 80
hour weeks at the office,
trying to build something but
I feel like I don't
have like that direction.
- [Gary] The North Star?
- Right, I have all this energy
but where do
I want to go with it?
- [Gary] Yeah. I think
that's a good question.
And I think (sighs)
I think one of the
reason's I've won is that
I didn't stress about that.
Outside of buying
the New York Jets,
when I was
building Wine Library,
even starting VaynerMedia, I had
a general idea of like here's
VaynerMedia's thesis.
If I scale me
and what I'm good at,
good things will happen.
I knew nothing about
the advertising industry.
I didn't know exactly
what good things meant.
So one of the things I would
tell you is that you don't have
to cripple yourself on
what am I working towards.
What's my strategy?
Especially not at this age.
The number one thing you should
focus on is to get as many
powerful and smart people within
your company and in the city of
Detroit to know that
you have that energy.
- [Andrew] Gotcha.
- That is far more powerful
than anything you can imagine.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Make sure Dan Gilbert's
mafia in Detroit.
- [Carmine] Totally,
we're part of his like family.
- Great. Make
sure they all know.
- [Carmine] Gotcha.
- Got it?
- [Carmine] Totally.
- That's it.
That is ROI positive.
Like people is the game.
All my friends and
contemporaries wanted to change
the world as a
disguise to become rich.
And I think I'm going
about it the other way.
I on paper seem quite you know,
narcissistic and things of that
nature to do the reverse.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- [Gary] Which is really rad.
I'd much rather
start off as the selfish,
self promoter,
Barnum and Bailey,
Billy Mays character who
actually did the right thing.
Got it?
Such a pleasure.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
Pleasure to meet you, man.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- [Andrew] You
excited for Ghana?
- [Gary] I am.
Gonna spent some time
with a bunch of team members.
Now that I think we're on the
dawn of becoming the creative
AOR, 'cause that's what
I think is happening, right?
Like our perspective is
we're gonna be below the line.
We think that
Facebook commercials
are television commercials.
We think that everybody will
trade on that currency in 24 to
36 months and we think we're
gonna be the disproportionate,
you know the compounded impact,
I just genuinely think that we
are that shop when this all
plays out because we're gonna
have the five
years of being that loud,
that proud, that good at it.
I mean the videos
we're making right now,
we finally are actually making
output to my hyperbole and now
we will, now the
easy part's ahead of us.
The tough part
was getting there.
We are gonna produce 50, 500
examples of Facebook commercials
not television commercials
that are gonna do well.
The (censored) work is
starting to really matter.
So like (censored)
entire above the line
creative TVC's for the
entire summer originated
as Facebook commercials.
Facebook is so special because
it's Google meets television.
- [Woman 2] Yes, yes.
- [Gary] And what that means is
when I figured it out in 2000 as
a kid, 2001 or '02 and grew my
business and wish I spent more
on Google, that's what drives me
so hard into going to you is my
regret of not building a 200,
you've heard that spiel from me.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- [Gary] Here's the difference,
I just had blue letters that
said Silver Oak Cabernet.
You know the vulnerability to
Facebook is the creative part.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- [Gary] Which is
why but it's so powerful.
Because on the flip side,
the reason people
like "Where's the beef?"
and "Just Do It"
is the creative part.
I mean it's so special what you
guys are actually sitting on.
If you're able to hit the
crescendo moment of keeping the
attention of the world,
still in your feed,
and the market catching
up to what we already know,
it makes your $150 stock price
look like the
best buy in the world.
I could sit and listen to every
fucking story from 1958 agencies
to 1991 agencies.
What you learn from other
people and what you guys lived,
for the rest of my life.
- [Avi] Right.
- It's the biggest value.
I love that shit.
And look,
I'm getting goosebumps.
It's how I make decisions.
On the flip side, I know what
your writing is and I know it
better than anybody on
Earth and I think I can help
and I like that.
Such a pleasure. Yeah.
Have a great day.
- [Avi] Take care, Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you.
("LA To Paris
(Instrumental)" by Koko)
So that dude's sleeping
and she's hustling and I am
coming off a red eye right to a
bunch of meetings,
right to the airport and
now this long flight to Ghana.
So Justin, I don't know what you
have for this episode but I said
my piece a couple episodes ago.
This is just the way it is.
Just grinding.
Hope everybody's super well.
Hope everybody's
trying really hard.
("LA To Paris
(Instrumental)" by Koko)
Hope everybody's trying to
figure themselves out because
once you figure it
out it all happens.
Cutest couple ever, by the way.
Love these two.
Love.